oui
c'était faux la revend là ça peut être
évident de leur parti a donc donc j'ai
pas de bananes j'ai pas des vidéos j'ai
pas de ce live en revanche d histoire à
vous raconter
donc on va finir comme ça en vous
racontant des histoires je vais partager
une petite histoire avec vous j'ai pas
trop parler de torny car que vous
connaissez peut-être que vous avez vu
effectivement dans le hall lg pas faire
la promo d'une start up
je vais essayer de te partager avec vous
arrange une histoire qui m'est cher et
qu'il reste peut-être à ceux qui voient
dans le monde qui nous entoure dans la
vie des hasards des signes parfois on
rencontre quelqu'un aussi c'est bizarre
j'en pensais de personnes à tel moment
votre pourquoi et c'est quelque chose
qui m'a qui m'a longtemps interrogé
savoir pourquoi est ce que ce que ça
arrive à tel moment pour qu'on va
rencontrer telle personne et j'ai pas
mal lu de littérature de me dire
d'essayer de trouver des théories au
hasard à la chance ce qui nous arrive
tous les jours et et un jour il m'est
arrivé cette petite ces petites
histoires je vous racontais et où j'ai
trouvé une explication à tout ça donc
j'aimerais la partager avec vous donc
c'était un soir de printemps une après
midi de printemps il ya deux ans
maintenant
j'étais dans un dans un parc à paris
parc de belleville
j'écrivais des bêtises dans un petit
carnet et puis je mets la main dans ma
poche avant d'aller puis je me retrouve
avec une invitation pour un point film
que vous êtes tête vue s'appelle the
grand budapest hôtel je peux
certainement vu un film en tout cas que
j'ai pu couper mais peu importe
donc je me rends au cinéma me disent
écoutez c'est beau
du coup c'est pas ça va peut-être sens
les faits pour jouer au cinéma mais en
tout cas je le cinéma et
et voilà donc je regarde le film super
sympa cet été atteint l'histoire c'est
pas ça c'est après ce qui se passe et
comme qu'est ce qui se passe après je
rentre chez moi et qui est toujours bon
sur au printemps je me dis tiens j'ai
par exemple tout de suite donc je me
posais intéresse de casey et je compte
quitter la banque
ce que je prendrais aucun aucun en
silence sur ce qui va se passer après
mensonges et intérêts mans et la voilà
donc le seul peut-être de la peine un
petit peu mais je suis très content j'ai
très bien ma femme et à ma gauche de
touristes me demande de prendre une
photo d'elle donc j'ai bien élevé guy
hoquet break moto est forcément dans
l'ue en discuter et là c'est ce qu'il me
raconte que l'histoire un ted
enfin le truc important de l'énergie en
angola mais bref et donc qu'est ce qui
se passe après
forcément la question qu'on pose dans
ces moments là vous venez en anglais
évidemment web commun et la réponse
réponse je vous affronter l'histoire
avant que normalement il ya un lien
depuis la peste depuis la baisse est
donc là quelle probabilité la ja je pars
faire des trucs avec les cas récents et
ses 75 n'importe quel produit théia pour
rencontrer à ce moment là quelqu'un qui
vient de budapest est donc là on
commence à parler de tous et tous ces
hasards de la vie
pourquoi pourquoi maintenant pourquoi là
j'ai jamais rencontré deux personnes à
budapest un café je devais pas aller
voir ce film et ses satellites attend
quelqu'un à qui ont rien à faire de tout
ce que je raconte à peut-être y en a
quelques-uns qui c'est marrant ça avait
déjà raté des trucs comme ça je te parle
plus à cela ce soir et est donc
eh bien là une des deux une des deux
filles qui étaient là m'a donné ma dit
quelque chose qui résonne encore dans ma
tête et m'a donné la première
explication un truc qui me voilà en tout
cas m'a parlé donc j'aimerais la
partager avec vous elle m'a dit écoute
alexandre labadie avec 110 écoute en
anglais puis ça et l asie quand il se
passe des choses comme ça dans ta vie
c'est que tu es sur la bonne route et
c'est un truc qui m'a qui m'a marqué et
qui va donc quand il fait des choses
comme ça tu es sur la bonne route
ouais c'est pas par une grande théorisée
par un grand truc mais en fait en y
repensant et c'est un truc qui depuis ma
compagne dans beaucoup de choses à
chaque fois que je vois des hasards et
des choses comme ça je repense à cette
phrase est ce que ça peut vouloir dire
sur la bonne route
et pour moi c'est exactement ça c'est à
dire que en fait tout est lié un peu
aussi à ce qu'on ressent un instant ça
veut dire que peut-être parle beaucoup
des trucs vous savez le flou et c'est
quand on est dans le flou tout se passe
bien et sait et c'est vrai qu'il ya
parfois il est est ressentie ces moments
où on se sent bien on sait pas pourquoi
je sais bien
j'ai pas tout se passe bien qu'on est
content la vie est belle et on sent que
ça fait du sens quoi et en fait
peut-être que c'est juste qu'on est on
est juste en tout cas notre instinct et
réceptifs à ce qui se passe on a envie
de voir ces trucs on aime bien un peu
même les horoscopes antully plus
personne n'y croit
ah oui c'est bon ça c'est vrai ça m'est
arrivé alors que l'on sait très bien que
c'est n'importe quoi mais mais ça marche
parfois et on aime bien ce truc là et en
fait pourquoi parce que ça nous parle
profondément et j'ai orienté des petites
histoires encore un petit peu de temps
patrons et les pour vous montrer à quel
point en fait c'est il faut être
attentif dans la vie à quand ça se passe
bien et que quand au contraire ça se
passe pas bien ou ensemble on force un
peu sur des trucs qu'on devrait pas on
n'aurait pas y aller et là il devrait
peut-être pas y aller parce qu'en fait
on n'est peut-être pas en accord avec
ces choses là et on est au fond de soi
je pense qu'on a toutes les clés
on sait en fait ce qui est bon ou pas
pour nous et on doit donc donc quoi donc
ce que je peux vous raconter petite
histoire rapide par exemple mon rap très
rapidement ornicar cesse est certain que
j'ai cofondé effectivement il ya à peu
près en même temps d'ailleurs il ya deux
ans troisième projet troisième aventure
entrepreneurs pour moi et
et là c'est marrant tous alliés une
croix georges premier truc on présente
un concours organisé par xavier niel
marc simoncini et jacques-antoine
granjon donc les boîtes d'ailleurs c'est
free meetic vente privee.com qui
s'adresse à un billet d'entrepreneur il
faut déposer un dossier des retraites y
retiennent 300 dossiers et 300 dossiers
qui vont pitch et on a une minute pour
convaincre sur scène des détroits bon
bref on est retournés 300 je vais
pitcher le projet et à la fin ils se
retiennent 101 on s'appelle le concours
des sons un projet est donc non
seulement pour jupiter machin soit bien
en français j'ai l'impression que ça se
passe plutôt bien
non seulement on est retenu en abaissant
un mais en plus on finit numéro un de la
liste
déjà tu commences un projet comme ça du
tout un concours j'ai fait me numéro
analyse suis ok ensuite qu'est ce qui se
passe dans le prolongement cette
histoire on fait commencé à bosser sur
le projet du coup et là on gagne 13
concours de startups pains 13-13 c'est
donc c'est à dire qu'il n'ya pas aucune
star trek en france gagné autant
concours sa première année n'existe pas
donc ok donc nous verrons à ce concours
de startups les plus primés qu'est-ce
qui se passe ensuite il ya des ponts
préfet des petites histoires et les
auto-écoles sa tatie est en fait
qu'est-ce qui se passe
eh ben on se retrouve à faire la une du
new york times a encore rien c'est on
n'a rien fait rien c'est juste une idée
donc ok donc tu as gagné 13 concours tu
fais une new york times ok bon c'est bon
et puis en fait tu te rends compte
qu'après ça continue comme ça on est
reçue à l'elysée on assure matignon
était aussi permis de conduire plein de
trucs et tu dis quoi la whey il ya un
truc ça se passe bien à quoi ça se passe
bien
alors qu'avant ça faisait deux projets
je m'étais j'étais encore rsa je
galérais tatati là ça marche
donc voilà donc petit truc pour vous
dire que parfois ça marche et qu'en fait
il faut y aller et peut-être que les
deux avant j'aurais peut-être dû
m'arrêter avant de trop forcer
mais donc voilà donc des petites
histoires parce qu'on raconte des
petites histoires là ce soir je vais
continuer autre petite histoire il ya
quatre ans je me suis fixé un truc sais
pas pourquoi j'avais envie d'aller voir
une personne que je connaissais qui est
à istanbul
mais j'avais pas envie d'y aller avec un
avion un truc comme enfant normal
normalement je me suis dit j'ai habité
paris à l'époque je veux y aller avec 20
euros
c'est ce que j'ai donc la tuque ans est
ajustée hors du hockey par istanbul 20
euros pas évident et en fait
en fait il réussit comment ça s'est fait
en fait je suis parti de lyon à paris
j'ai pris je vais un ticket de métro 20
euros et un ticket métro
j'ai été le plus loin possible paris
devrait reprendre entre eux près d'une
station service pour pouvoir commencer à
faire du stop et donc j'ai parti je ne
savais pas du tout où j'allais dormir ou
lin etc et je suis parti et ont même pas
dix jours je vais arriver à istanbul en
dormant donc j'ai des personnes que je
connaissais pas en étant invité à 1
à manger chez ces personnes me faire
aider aux sessions service tiens j'ai
encore un truc c est donc je suis arrivé
à istanbul et donc pendant tout ce truc
il ya cette sorte d'énergie que
peut-être bouleversante u2 ressens tu
ressenti parfois ou en fait ça se passe
bien on sait qu'il ya un truc hyper
sport dernier où on est c'est pas
possible ça ne fonctionne pas quoi je
savais dès le début que j'allais arriver
à istanbul en fait j'y croyais et il y
avait 7 7 7
cette force quoi qu'ils étaient là et en
fait ouais ça est en jeu même et donc
sur ces 20 euros il m'en restait 14 à la
fin j'ai craqué j'ai acheté un petit
marsouins lyon j'étais coincé son
service donc vous voyez en fait voilà
donc en fait quand on il ya plein de
trucs des recettes vont partager
l'histoire je vais pas si encore un fil
rouge vous allez voir on va essayer de
revenir un peu sur la bonne route très
bien aussi
et voilà donc là c'est une histoire
voilà où l'apparence ça se passe bien le
flou machin en avance autres petites
histoires à partager avec vous c'était
ça s'est moins bien passé
la cc moyen passé c'était quoi en fait
c'était un petit bol encore un truc pour
que je me décide comme c'est un peu
débile
l'idée d'assister de traverser 19 à pied
il ya un lien du coup avec eux avec
justement traversée ils sont à pied mais
en autonomie complète donc avec un mois
de coupure d'eau la canne à pêche ou le
producteur et
et voilà donc ça c'était quelques années
aussi et donc voilà je parle en islande
et où il fait chaud et non pas tant que
ça mais en tout cas il fait jour c'est
très pratique pour pour partir marcher
et faire des randos c'est parce qu'en
fait il fait jour tout le temps donc au
moins quand et attentes et que la nuit
tu veux sortir faire pipi
par exemple eh ben moi je ne prends pas
les pieds dans la sardine et truc il
fait jour ces pratiques en fait c'est un
pays très bien pour et donc bref je vais
la barre parenthèse qui en 15 ans gens
comme ça c'était pas le but
et donc voilà donc là j'aimerais partir
un mois
sam était normalement un mois de
traversée d'islande est en fait au bout
de ces trucs je ne sentais pas et je le
sentais pas et en fait au bout de dix
jours le retrouve au bord d'un lac au
milieu de nulle part avec mon petit
cousin objets l'emmener avec moi
le pauvre est en fait on se retrouve
c'était magnifique et on commence à
pêcher ou peugeot en rien sa santé
mauvais sa santé vendus et la normale
ont tort on se réveille et puis normal
et puis là qu'est ce qui se passe
eh ben
un peu si leur part de remarcher c'est
bien pourtant jupe à bionic vous avez vu
rien à voir avec les trucs qu'on a vus
avant tendinite mais un truc je n'aime
pas que ça pouvait arriver comme ça en
fait vous ne peut pas utiliser peut plus
marcher genre mais pas plus et tous les
deux en même temps quoi trucs
hallucinants voir ça faisait une semaine
qu'on marche et ce même après ça arrive
maintenant et au bénin et tout
impossible de remarcher
ok qu'est ce qu'on fait on est aux
portes on n'a pas de téléphone n'avait
rien qu'en islande
j'ai plus marché personnes qui passent
les stands juste pour que vous sachiez
c'est quand même c 308 personnes dans
tout le pays
308 personnes c'est quoi c'est dans ton
post beaucoup plus donc métropole donc
donc ouais donc donc voilà donc on
n'était pas au top
et puis et puis en fait bon bref on
arrive à s'en sortir je suis je pas
pourquoi mes histoires
et donc voilà je vais pas vous dire là
par exemple ça marchait pas et en fait
ouais c'est vrai que c'est bon
l'histoire registre que ça marchait pas
quoi mais ça marchait pas et en fait on
le sait quoi je savais très bien que ça
marchait pas ce truc quoi je le sentais
pas alors qu'ils sont en boule pas de
problème 20 euros c'est bon les quais
alors qu'en soirée c'était plus facile
je vais en route bref donc voilà c'est
vrai je vais reprendre et c'est de
retourner un peu sur un fil rouge quand
même je vais revenir sur un peu
saint-exupéry ça va pas le parler aussi
donc c'est bien en fait sa part à tout
le moins saint-exupéry et notamment
cette histoire de bateaux peut-être
parce que moi j'ai un papa qui vit sur
un bateau depuis dix ans donc
donc ça me parle et en fait partager
aussi petite métaphore avec l'excellent
rouge encore eu
ouais donc le peut-être dû faire en fait
des slides moi j'arrivais un plan est en
fait ouais non un petit petit petit
métaphore ce dessus sur 7 sur 7 7
peut-être que c'est bien effectivement
d'avoir un cap dans la vie et c'est
important et en fait je pense est
effectivement le principal d'avoir une
direction est pont n'y a pas de
meilleure métaphore que celui du bateau
à voile
pourquoi pourquoi ben je sais pas s'il y
en a qui font un peu de bateaux ici mais
quand on monte sur un bateau et qu'on
met pas de cap et ben en fait c'est la
situation la plus désagréable possible
c'est à dire que ça bouge dans tous les
sens ça fait du bruit
bing bing tatata tous les bruits là on
sait pas quoi faire
les gens autour de nous savent pas quoi
faire non plus donc généralement on
s'engueule un peu on sait pas trop
on a la gerbe parce que ça bouge dans
tous les sens et on n'avance pas quoi et
donc en fait c'est infini alors qu'en
fait c'est un truc formidable il suffit
de mettre un cap juste dire allez tiens
on va là-bas même si on sait pas où on
va on va là-bas j'y tiens voilà et ben
était que tu dis tu vas là-bas et ballon
tu m'aimes avec les voilà maintenant et
bien le bateau commence à fondre la
houle et c'est ça devient agréable les
gens savent quoi faire on s'aide et c
est là et voilà et en fait on se rend
compte que juste d'avoir une direction
ben en fait ça suffit a en tout cas être
bien et donc ça quand même lire un peu
avec le truc de bonnes routes veille
mais c'est donc en fait tout ça pour
vous dire
non mais c'est juste ça en fait sérieux
de retenir que dans la vie juste six
essais essayez d'être sensible un peu ce
qui vous entoure et en tout cas moi ça
m'a réussi
et je pense que ça réussit à toutes les
personnes qui font un peu attention à ça
à se dire ils n'arrivent pas quelque
chose par hasard ou en tout cas si je
fais un peu attention aussi je suis
sensible à ce qui m'arrive est bas alors
ça se passe bien et donc en fait juste
se dire quand ils savent quand il arrive
des choses comme ça on est sur la bonne
route
voilà